was bringt mich zur aussage der frau
kollegin karachi mit der ich heute
morgen auch schon gesprochen habe weil
wir eigentlich noch in einer schalte am
montag eben auch gemeinsam jahr darüber
gesprochen haben wir die situation ist
es war von anfang an klar dass es knapp
sein würde zu beginn
es war von anfang an klar dass das was
wir an theoretischer impf kapazität
vorhalten
also was geimpft werden könnte am tag
höher sein wird als die zahl der zur
verfügung stehenden dosen finde ich aber
besser als andersrum weil wir uns eben
bestmöglich vorbereitet haben und das
jetzt sozusagen zug um zug über die zeit
dann auch weiter hochgefahren werden
kann
und andersrum halte ich wenig davon wir
sind alle gerade in einer
herausfordernden situation insbesondere
die 16 kolleginnen und kollegen
gesundheitsminister in den bundesländern
wie im bund in europa wenig davon fragen
unter stress öffentlich auszutragen und
daran werde ich mich nicht beteiligen